you
hi everyone is cherry this is game 5
from the 2014 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand going into this round both players
remain level they had two points apiece
and Anand with the white pieces in this
one he opened with d4 we have yet to see
anything different when a nod has the
white side games one and three saw the
same thing all the things be different
in this one after Knight f6 c4 and e6
we're following game three so far with
still Knight f3 in game 3 at this moment
here we saw d5 this is where things
change instead we enter a Queen's Indian
with b6 g3 black inserts this check in
order to inconvenience the Queen Bishop
and only then return to e7 this is a bit
awkward with the bishop on d2 it's off
the back rank but it gets in the way of
the Queen from seeing the DS d4 and d5
squares so eventually he'll have to move
again Knight c3 Bishop d7 Bishop g2 and
with c6 black is prepping this d5
advance wipe lazy 4 there's castles as
well here and e4 well white goes with e4
looking to maybe kick the knight around
if black is careless with castles that's
something that we likely would not have
but after e4 it is instead black
following through swinging the back
completely around d5 it is and now he
takes D doing something other than he
takes D such as a 5 the knight can
simply drop right into the center and is
immune from capture Knight takes pawn
takes he's hit and d4 would fall so it
is instead he takes D C takes D and now
Knight to e5 a typical move when you
have that King side fianchettoed Bishop
you will
for that opportunity in other words to
move the night open the diagonal and
well improve the night's position really
95 does just that and now this pawn on
the d5 squares in a pin both sides
castle and now Knight to c6 challenging
the one piece in the black position
getting another developing move in C
takes Dean and not the immediate
recapture this is a very delicate
position it's delicate or it's critical
because there are ways that the pawn
structure can change as an example if
black is immediately recapturing on d5
with the knight there can follow Knight
takes Knight end after the pawn takes we
have this RAM structure and white has
some play here after Queen to a4
pressure on c6 ensuing pressure here and
if black wants to release that you may
very well have to change the structure
again and I don't know how favorable
structure this is on the black side I
don't know that this is an asset in such
a position to work with an isolated deep
on in such a simplified position white
would have a very strong pawn chain and
can play against that deep on rook a to
d1 bishop c3 very nice posts for the
white pieces so in other words black
will not be so quick to recapture on d5
after C takes D we don't have Knight
takes but rather knight on C takes e5
and now white two needs to be careful we
don't have the immediate recapture but
instead something else if d takes EE in
this position we can now have Knight
takes d5 and this pawn on e5 is I think
we can say a bit overextended I don't
know that this is so inconvenient to the
black side and I'm seeing it more as a
liability than an asset
one day could even have this bishop
putting pressure on this pond I think we
could quickly have a good versus bad
bishop type of situation as an example
if rook c1 we can have Knight takes
Knight Bishop takes Bishop takes King
takes and exchange Queens I don't know
that there's really anything so wrong
with that and again this pawn one day
could maybe be targeted will really be
enough for its it's not any better for
any side but I'm just seeing no benefit
to go into this variation where there's
a pawn on e5 and a potential target we
don't have that we don't once again just
like we did not have an immediate
recapture on d5 with a knight or a pond
after Knight takes on e5 we don't have
an immediate recapture but instead this
sneaky move d6
hitting the bishop and throwing a punch
at this unprotected Queen Bishop on b7
the follow up is Knight to c6 keep in
mind if as white you go ahead excuse me
if as black you go ahead and capture on
g2 I'll notice you're now going to have
to play position where you have the rook
versus White's two minor pieces since D
takes east seven is coming with great
effect
that's a fork Queen takes pawn is
necessary and now you still don't do
anything about the bishop on g2 have a
lot of in-between moves here these past
few variations pawn takes Knight would
follow and after Bishop takes rook like
I was saying we would enter a position
where it's a rook and a pawn in this
case a rook in a pond versus the two
minor pieces white stands the better
side will have perfect homes for these
minor pieces and while there's this open
file not really one that could be made
use of bishop on e3 is a fantastic piece
would watch over the D 2 square that
entry point for a black rook night in
the night is watching over d1 white is
without
the preferred side so that's why we're
not having Bishop takes Bishop here but
instead knight c6 and with this white is
able to do what exactly well they've
just picked up the bishop pair and now
with Bishop g5 throws the knight in a
pin looking for ideas such as d5
breaking in the center maybe jumping a
knight in to d5 exploiting the pin
against the knight so let's see how
black copes with that first trying to
get out of the pen with h6 throws a
question to that guy and once again we
have this in-between move many in
between moves so far in this game not
the typical reaction to this threat to
the thread on the bishop but rather d5
throwing a punch at the night the night
runs to the edge doing something other
than that well black is getting killed I
was saying here this would be piling up
on that pinned piece striking at Queen
the Queen and the knight so therefore
the knight immediately runs away doing
something else like taking the bishop
well this is a passed pawn and he's
throwing a punch at the bishop this is
not a good idea for the black side it's
too strong so we have the knight
immediately reacting to the threat
Knight a5 it is and now Bishop takes
Knight finally Queen takes and then pawn
takes I would like to point out one
variation here it's very important at
this stage here after Bishop to g5 and
h6 it's very important that you not
let's say only go here to induce this
weakness such as this h6 move or in
other words if you're dropping back if
you're doing something that's strictly
defensive or reactionary not posing a
great threat or not throwing a strong
punch with your next move if you're
dropping back for some reason to e3
here's how bad things can turn for white
from a positional standpoint from a
strategic standpoint there's this very
convenient reply Knight B for the light
square Bishop will be exchanged and
night will be enormous on the d5 square
the short story here is that black will
have a wonderful position where there is
a strong knight on d5 that will
essentially go unchallenged white will
our black will have a strong night
versus a very bad Bishop on III white in
other words is wise to make sure he
takes out this knight
otherwise he's kind of a dead piece in
the position so after d5 Knight a5 sure
enough we do have Bishop takes Knight
Queen takes D takes e Queen take C and
now rook to e1 very logical playing on
an open file in doing so with tempo
Queen f6 the most logical move very good
move keeping her off of the open files
keeping a watchful eye over the e7
square potential entry point for a white
rook and staying out of harm's way of
the light square bishop if there's only
one color Bishop remaining ideally if
you can you'd like to keep your queen on
an opposite color so there's no ensuing
tempo type moves against her by the
bishop at least following up Knight d5
well as it stands right now let's just
take a moment to assess the position
there's no imbalance with those last
handful of moves as soon as this d5
advance was played right here
as soon as these guys are exchanged well
as it stands right now there's this
isolated pawn but as soon as he is
exchanged
there is no imbalance with regard to the
pawn structure liquidated central the
pawn structure in the center has been
liquidated and the attention now turns
towards peace activity no imbalance with
the pawn structure who stands better
however with the pieces white is the
preferable side if only because of let's
say these Knight positions he's not so
well placed on a5 and the one on c3 is a
bit better he could jump into d5 and he
does so right now that's what a nun
chooses on this move twenty Knight d5 it
is
so I was just saying there's no
imbalance with regard to palm structure
but now we do have an imbalance after
ninety-five Bishop takes Knight Bishop
takes Bishop look at how dominant this
Bishop is on d5 he is doing what exactly
it's doing everything basically boxing
out the knight there's not a great way
to get him back into playing the bishop
is also striking at f7 certainly a an
accessible point to not only a rook but
maybe even a queen when she arrives on
f3 we do in fact get to see that but
first things first
after this recapture on d5 the rook is
hit rook d8 nice reaction right the rook
was hit he reacts and now puts the
bishop in a pin white needs to get out
of that the typical get out of the pin
as soon as you can idea Queen f3 and now
Queen takes b2 this was an important
decision to take on b2 or do something
else taking on this square White has the
superior minor piece and will still be
pressing in this position for sure
trying to enter on the 7th rank and you
could give this knight a kick you could
enter here there might even be some
lines where the bishop is able to I
don't know throw throw a punch at one of
the black pieces and control h7 I don't
know that h7 at this point would be a
reliable flight square for the black
King g6 would probably be needed at some
point so this move an additional move in
other words would still be needed on the
black side before the King has a
reliable flight square whereas white has
absolutely no issues no no time would be
needed in order for the white King to be
nice and cozy with his flight Square g2
is perfect I should also note one other
important detail right here one other
important variation this moment right
here
that night was snapped right off with
Bishop takes Knight but this was a very
interesting line one that can also have
translated into an imbalance in the form
of two minor pieces versus a rook once
again in whites favor if the knight is
not taken here on this move xx by black
suppose Queen takes b2 there can follow
this very forcing line surprisingly
enough rook e to the Queen does not have
very many options in fact her only
choice is a3 going elsewhere where well
where else is she going to go b5 she
gets hit with the fork a3 is the only
safe Square Queen a3 now there's rook
III she is once again very limited going
to c5 runs into similar ideas right when
the rook played to e1 earlier that came
with tempo on the Queen this is once
again playing into what into White's
hands activating another piece so if the
Queen at this moment grabbed on b2
instead of Bishop takes Knight if we had
Queen takes pawn there can follow rookie
to Queen a3 rook III queen us to come
back here if she's going to d6 the queen
is falling now that's a check in the
Queen's gun so the Queen would have to
come back to be - there's rook b1 the
Queen has to take on a2 and others rook
back over to a1 how is this a little bit
different
why would white want to give up that a
pawn well now after the Queen moves
there's pressure here there can follow
rook takes Knight pawn takes Knight e7
check and after he moves there goes this
Bishop once again a situation where it's
the two minor pieces versus the rook and
pawn rook and two pawns there is a
outside pass pawn this is a very
difficult position to assess I'm not
sure who stands better the evaluation
will read that white is the better side
but in practice I'm not so sure this is
a very scary passed pawn not so easy for
the minor pieces to coordinate in a way
where they can prevent these guys from
advancing I'm not exactly sure who
stands better in this ending in the
earlier variation I was showing where
was the two minor pieces versus the rook
there was good coordination blackened in
that case did not have a passed pawn
things again however are a little bit
different here with black having an
outside pass pawn it's not a situation
at a variation we went into but
certainly something that was being
calculated by both sides instead we had
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop
rook a d8 Queen f3 and instead of this
move here we have blacks scooping up
upon rook a to d1 and now there's some
serious stuff happening light is down
upon but has great play here this Knight
has yet to do anything he's been
sidelined with this last move white is
already threatening ideas of simply
entering the seventh rank adding
additional pressure to f7 as well as
snipping that f7 pawn right away just to
highlight making a dummy move if a6
there's just capture on rook takes rook
you're dropping that rook in here in
fact it's already a million eight so my
main point here is that there is now two
ideas in mind by white as soon as the
replace to d1 playing here right away
you're dropping the rook so after rook a
d1 there's this move in mind snipping on
f7 and entering on e7 how does black
deal with that Queen f8 offering a queen
exchange Queens are exchanged at the
cost of damaging this structure white is
still able to enter this pawn is now hit
and f7 is hit
this is a threat in the position once
again just to highlight if a six this
Bishop takes f7 on rook takes once again
we're dropping that rook the f7 pawn
curiously enough right these guys here
are doubled and isolated however this
guy here is much more valuable than a7
without this guy around that means that
the white rook will be sealing this King
off from even thinking about getting
towards the center of the board which is
his ideal environment since we're in an
ending since we're in an endgame he
wants to be able to step up to g7 play
f5 and then make use of this f6 square
so while he's doubled again he turns out
to be much more important much more
valuable than this a seven pawn so
that's why we're having King g7 black
simply does nothing about this pawn here
there is now no Bishop takes pawn here
since it's not coming with check
rook takes a7 what was pointed out after
the game is that rook c7 would have been
another interesting try trying to do
what exactly
limit this Knight not allow him to get
back into play so easily with ideas of
maybe rook to d3 this is an interesting
idea of suppose a six rook d3 and let's
just make another passing move to
highlight a particular tactic that's
present if b5 there can follow Bishop
takes f7 and on rook d3 there's Bishop
to c4 getting this pawn back but we
didn't have rook c7 instead ruck takes a
so now the material is restored and the
attention once again still turns towards
what exactly the minor piece imbalance
and the King side pawn structure with
this last move white is now well white
was already in a pin this pin right here
is now being made use of Black's next
move knight c6 hits the rook
there is no Bishop takes Knight you're
dropping on d1 so knight c6 and now with
rook b7 we're essentially going to enter
a position
the queenside ponds have been exchanged
and this is exactly what black would
want when it's the bishop versus a
knight if you can exchange pawns in such
a way where they are only on one side of
the board the chessboard basically
becomes a bit more narrow a bit smaller
to work with a smaller environment is a
is a much more ideal environment if
you're the side who has the knight that
way he's not having to run from one side
of the board to the other the bishop he
has no issues with doing just that so
having these a and B pawns exchanges
exactly what black would want after
Knight to c6
we did have rook b7 another try in order
to keep these pawns on board would be
rook a4 but as was pointed out in the
game Anand was saying after rook d6
Bishop b3 and these rooks being
exchanged basically went as far as this
here saying that the knight on d4 would
be a very strong piece and it's tough to
say that this bishop would be any better
than the knight in this position so
instead of rook to a4 trying to preserve
these Queen side pawns on the board it
was instead rook b7 and now we have
these forcing moves Knight b4 rooks are
exchanged the a pawn drops the b-pawn
drops and now the knight can finally
return f5 is in and this is now
simplifying way too much there go the
bishop at night even if black was down
upon at this point it's close to being
holdable it's it's very close to
holdable of course but even you have to
play this position down upon f5 is in we
have a bunch of other exchanges III
exploits this pin that's not a problem
though riki for rook takes f2 King g3
and after rook takes f5 these guys agree
to a draw
and it's just a dead drop position
nothing to do at this point so this is a
match that remains level if you think
back to 2013 after game 4 I should say
game 5 was a decisive result and in that
in that match in the 2013 match
that's where Carlsen pulled ahead 3 to 2
but this time around we are split again
they are level 2 and 1/2 points each and
we go into round 6 tomorrow so we'll see
what takes shape then as always I hope
you got something out of this video take
care bye
you